the veteran right-hander johnny cueto
cueto 34 years of age and he is in his
13th year at the big league level
many aboard it first to a two down it
brings up tommy fan
on the ground to solano across the
diamond
side retired no runs a hit one left
the sheriff chris paddock on the hill
tonight 24 year old making a second
start after the opening day start how
about this 76 percent of his
first pitches were strikes 2-2 and that
is struck well headed out towards deep
left center field but it's a big
outfield and grisham is back there to
make the grab
in order go the giants against the
sheriff chris paddock
padres with traffic here in the second
hedge is looking for his first hit of
the year coming in all for nine
to crawford can they turn it flores to
sandoval they do
and that'll end the inning and the
giants coming up in the bottom of the
second inning with dickerson pence and
crawford
is dickerson skies this one into center
field
nob grisham going back still going back
and he didn't see it
and dickerson's on the move and he's
going for three
and he is going to make it i don't know
what happened
and that shoots by everybody
and the giants have a man at third with
nobody out he didn't see it
first and third one away here for the
giants
donovan solano standing in
up the middle and a base hit past the
diving garcia the giants are on the
board it's one nothing
he can hit he could hit that that's a
that's a back control at bat that's not
a bad pitch second time around for manny
machado with a runner on now
manny machado reaches out and sends this
one out to deep center field back goes
jastrepski and it's gone
a two-run home run for manny machado and
the padres with one swing of the bat
take a 2-1 lead
second home run of the year for machado
takes it out to center field
top of the order mike yustramski to lead
it off here for the giants
driven to right down the line is it fair
it is out of here
and this game is tied first of the year
for
mike yastrensky and good old dave's got
it
yastremski a no doubter in terms of
distance
splashes one into the bay 81 home runs
have been hit
in the water by giants hitters
80 of them from barry bonds
[Laughter]
it just seemed like i'm guessing that
all the varus
should get a pretty good pitch to hit
i know plato wants to face him with uh
first and second
this is a hot shot into left field to
base it and see if they send myers they
do
dickerson up and throwing it'll be cut
off and the padres back on top again
they take a 3-2 lead edward oliveira
strives in the go ahead run for the
friars
at second tatis at first with two down
and grisham hits this one to deep right
field that ball is back
and that ball is gone trent grisham with
a three-run home run gives the padres a
6-2 lead
another big home run for the friars
trent grisham with his second home run
of the year
and the padres open it up a three-run
blast
david bednar 6-1 250 pounder
and dickerson hits one high and deep
into center field
it is out of here
that's how you welcome mr bednar
dickerson's first of the year
with two down the giants have runners at
the corners
and the tie run coming to the plate here
high and deep to left
did solano tie it up it is
out of here how about that the giants
with a home run with people on base
three run blast with a six
six ball game from san francisco and you
have the top of the order coming up in
mike istramski
2-2 pitch there's a long drive and you
can forget about this one
off into the night headed for san
francisco bay
this ball game is over and yostremski
with a spectacular shot into the water
7-6 the giants have won it and what an
explosion that was
that is right there above the hands
middle in
and he knew it as soon as it left the
bat this was one of those barry bond
shots
where it made for an easy call and every
player's dream a walk off
and that tied the series